hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this is ai
simplified where we learn to make your
data
useful in the last few episodes we have
been covering different components of
vertex ai to get you familiar with
different features
in this video i thought we would help a
friend of mine
get into yoga so we are building a yoga
pulse classification model for some
simple yoga poses this will help her
hone her yoga skills
first of all let's see how we will make
this happen
we need the data to create our models
with
this would be in the form of images and
let's say we want to focus on
five poses the tree goddess warrior two
plank and down dog my colleague sarah
and i have collected
a bunch of images from our yoga practice
that we will be using to train this
model
our first step would be to ingest these
images using the managed data sets
and then label them appropriately
then comes trading the model and since
this is
an image classification problem it's a
good fit for auto ml
and as we covered in the last episode
you can totally create a custom model
from scratch if you wanted to
but auto ml is just the right fit for
this particular image classification
problem
once our model is trained we will
evaluate it
to understand the quality of our model
and indicate
areas of improvement now automl ui
provides us with easy to understand
charts for this that we will demystify
when i show you the console
then we will need an endpoint to serve
our models
for predictions after training our
automl model
we will be able to deploy an endpoint
with just one click
now that we have laid out the data
requirements and how we will train our
model
we are ready to jump into the console
and make it happen
first thing we need is the data for this
step
my friend sarah and i collected a bunch
of images from our yoga practice and
uploaded them
into the managed data sets as you see
here the images are labeled in five
categories
i can even upload unlabeled images and
label them
we can analyze our data set to see that
we have enough examples of each
categories
now we are ready to train our model in
here
i'm selecting automl for training method
you can also train a model to deploy on
the edge or on premise or use custom
training
if you're writing your own custom model
code
now we define our model
automl automatically splits the data
into training validation
and test but we can change it if we want
to
in compute and pricing we get to select
how many node hours we want to train the
model
at this point we wait for the model to
train
once it is trained we see it in the
model tab and can evaluate the model
we can see our model's average precision
it ranges from 0 to 1
where a higher value indicates a higher
quality model
we can see that the confusion matrix
helps us understand where our model is
confusing to results
now that we have evaluated our model
it's time to deploy it to an endpoint
we can split traffic between two models
deployed on the same endpoint if needed
allocate the number of nodes needed for
this endpoint
depending on where your users are select
the region to deploy your
endpoint and that's it hit deploy and we
have an endpoint
now we can test our endpoint and the
model by uploading an image
and yay it works you can also make
predictions using the sdk
all right so today we created a yoga
pose classification model where we
uploaded our data sets in vertex ai
labeled our images in the ui and then
used automl to train our model
then we evaluated it and then deployed
it for making predictions with just one
clip
i know my friend will be extremely happy
to use this model to hone her yoga
skills
stay tuned for the next episode which is
all about using vertex ai sdk
in the meantime give us a like and
subscribe and share with me your
thoughts about this series in the
comments below
you